Guten Tag, meine Damen und Herren, wir
sind Lucas Graham und ähm, wir werden ein
bisschen Musik für Sie spielen.
Vielen Dank für Ihr
heutiges Erscheinen. Wir feiern unsere aktuelle
Position in den deutschen Charts auf Platz
25. Tschüss,
Mädchen, ich habe eine Frage: Sie
Ich bin immer noch wach genug, um dich zu sehen.
Bitte hör einfach zu. Ja, ich weiß, es ist
spät, aber besser spät als
nie  Ich hoffe,
du willst, dass ich mich will,
wenn du mich reden hörst.
Du weißt, dass ich weg war und ist es
in Ordnung, wenn ich an
dem
Morgen, an dem ich dich anrufe, vorbeikomme, wenn ich betrunken bin,
könntest du einsam sein,
einsam, wenn ich sie noch mehr betrinke
Ich rufe
dich, du bist vielleicht einsam, einsam,
oh,
ich und Sophie. Ich küsse
Baby Sarah, das ich in meiner Hand hatte, aber ich
rufe
dich, aber nicht bevor es nach 14:00 Uhr ist, denn
ich spiele mit meinen Jungs, meinen Jungs, meinen
Jungs  Ich weiß, es ist 5 Uhr
morgens. Sicherlich rufe ich an.
Du hast seit einiger Zeit nichts mehr von mir gehört,
Mädchen. Ich hoffe, du willst, dass ich W-Mich bin,
wenn du mich reden hörst.
Du weißt, dass ich draußen war und ist es
in Ordnung?  Komm
vorbei, wenn ich morgens Müll mache.
Ich rufe
dich an, du gehörst vielleicht dazu. Oh, ich rufe dich nur an,
wenn ich morgens betrunken bin. Ich
rufe
dich an, du bist vielleicht einsam,
einsam. Ich weiß, du bist froh, dass ich angerufen habe, jetzt
kannst du es  Hab alles, wenn wir zusammen sind.
Du wirst wissen, wie es sein sollte, wenn du
betrunken bist. Vielleicht sollten wir gehen, Mädchen, und
etwas Zeit alleine verbringen, Mädchen, du bist so
schön, wenn ich
betrunken bin, wenn ich betrunken bin,
ja, wenn ich  Wenn ich
morgens betrunken bin, rufe ich
dich an, du könntest einsam und
einsam sein, wenn ich
morgens fertig bin. Ich rufe dich an. Du
rufst dich vielleicht an, wenn ich morgens trinke. Ich
rufe dich an  Ich bin
Juni, ich rufe
Sie an, Sie könnten einsam sein.
Vielen Dank, meine Damen und
Herren